Die Welt wandelt sich -
auch jene der Winzer.
Für manche Schweizer Weinbauern
steht die Zukunft auf dem Spiel.
In Genf will Damien Mermoud
gegen den Rat seines Vaters
ins Geschäft einsteigen.
Er sagte mir: "Mach was anderes!"
Wer das mit Leidenschaft macht,
opfert leicht
sein ganzes Leben dafür.
Im Lavaux hat Pierre Monachon
den Betrieb
seinem Sohn Basile übergeben.
Mit seinen Kindern zu arbeiten, ist
genauso heikel wie mit seinem Vater.
Jetzt habe ich das Sagen,
aber sicher müssen wir wachsen.
Im Tessin
wird das riesige Weingut Tamborini
nach Generationen
der Männerherrschaft
nun von dieser jungen Frau,
Valentina, geleitet.
Als Frau hat man es
in diesem Metier nicht leicht.
Es ist nach wie vor
eine Männerdomäne.
In Graubünden
strebt Irene Grünenfelder
gegen den Willen ihrer Kinder
das Bio-Zertifikat an.
Es ist einfach Schwachsinn!
Auf dem Weg hoch zum Weingut
denke ich mir immer:
wunderschön, aber stark gefährdet.
Und im Wallis führt Marion Granges
mit aller Kraft
eines der Vorzeigegüter.
Sie ist die Seele
des Weinguts Beudon.
Die Winzerin der Berggipfel,
die einen Nachfolger sucht.
Für diese fünf Winzerinnen und Winzer
ist der Jahresverlauf
voller Ungewissheit.
Vier Jahreszeiten.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ende Juni,
der Sommer hat gerade erst begonnen,
gibt es erste Anzeichen
einer bevorstehenden Dürre.
In Beudon fliesst kein Wasser mehr.
Diese Leitungen versorgen
das ganze Weingut direkt ab Quelle.
Hier in Beudon
gab es immer Wasser,
sonst wäre hier
keine Siedlung entstanden.
Der Zufluss des lebensnotwendigen
Wassers wurde irgendwo unterbrochen.
Wohl durch Geröll. Marion muss
zum Wasserfall aufsteigen.
Ihre beiden Mitarbeiter
begleiten sie.
Zum Glück kann sie sich
auf Christian verlassen -
ein Bauer, der sich
mit diesem Terrain auskennt
und gerade erst aus den Berner Alpen
hergekommen ist.
Ich wollte nur kurz schauen,
wie es da aussieht.
Ja, das muss alles weg,
das ist das Problem.
Das ist viel Arbeit.
Da seid ihr eine Weile dran,
bis das alles weggeräumt ist.
Wir müssen alle Steinbrocken
aus diesem Becken hier holen.
Diese Steine müssen alle weg.
Das muss geleert werden.
Okay, also dahin?
- Ja, wir werfen die Steine dahin.
Nicht auf die Seite,
sondern auf diese Seite hier.
Wenn das jetzt austrocknet,
wenn die Reben
ihre Blätter verlieren,
dann gibt es keine Ernte.
Ganz einfach. Dann sterben sie ab.
Im September gibt's vielleicht
Regen, dann kommen sie wieder.
Aber die Trauben entwickeln sich
so nicht mehr richtig.
Da muss noch
der eine oder andere Stein weg.
Nimm die Steine mal da weg!
* Sanfte Musik *
In Beudon fliesst das Wasser wieder.
Am anderen Ende des Landes, ganz
im Osten der Schweizer Rebberge,
kämpfen auch Irene und ihr Sohn
Johannes mit den Folgen der Dürre.
Es hat praktisch kaum geregnet,
war immer sonnig.
Das hat eine Kehrseite:
V.a. die jungen Rebenanlagen
beginnen langsam zu leiden.
Jetzt müssen wir Wasser geben.
Also v.a.
den drei- und vierjährigen,
die etwas
in sich zusammengefallen sind.
Johannes holt Nachschub.
In Jenins wurde das Wasser
mit dem Tankwagen angeliefert.
2018 erinnert langsam an 2003,
dem bisher heissesten Jahr
seit der Jahrtausendwende.
Heiss, heiss, heiss
und sehr trocken.
Es ist wie 2003.
Damals war es
fast noch eine Spur trockener.
Aber wir sind nahe dran.
Ich hoffe, dass wir im Herbst
nicht zu üppige Weine kriegen,
damit doch noch etwas Frische
enthalten ist
und es nicht
ein zu dichter Wein wird.
Um die Rebenanlage
gegen die Dürre zu wappnen,
hat Irene
eine eigene Strategie entwickelt.
Bei älteren Anlagen
überleben die Reben gut,
weil die Wurzeln sehr tief gehen.
Wir haben lehmhaltige Böden, darum
wird das Wasser zurückgehalten.
Ich finde, Reben müssen lernen,
in die Tiefe zu gehen.
Wenn man sie oben immer verwöhnt,
indem man sie oben bewässert,
geht sie nie in die Tiefe und wird
nie eine Trockenheit überstehen.
Bei Grünenfelders
trägt man den Böden besonders Sorge,
denn dieses Jahr möchte sich Irene
für das Bio-Siegel
zertifizieren lassen.
Jedes Detail zählt.
* Antreibende Musik *
Jetzt hoffen wir,
dass es bald wieder einmal regnet.
Das ist gut.
Sanfter Regen ohne Hagel.
Im Lavaux
herrscht ebenfalls Wassermangel,
auch wenn das auf den ersten Blick
nicht so scheint.
An den Hängen in Rivaz macht Basile
einen Rundgang durch die Parzellen
und trifft dabei
auf seinen Nachbarn Gille.
Na, wie geht's?
Gut und dir?
- Ziemlich trocken.
Hast du gesehen,
fast alle Geiztriebe sind verdorrt.
Hier ist noch einer, der ...
- ... der ist noch gut.
Aber auch schon etwas gelb.
Und hier erkennt man sehr gut,
dass er verdorrt ist.
Gut, dass ihr sie bewässert.
Aber das ist auch
eine trockene Ecke, oder?
Ja, die Böden filtern und entwässern
stark, daher ist es trocken.
Bewässert ihr hier zum ersten Mal?
- Ja.
Ich habe den Betrieb
2015 übernommen.
Wir haben einen trockenen Frühling
und Sommeranfang,
der Regen kommt einfach nicht.
Und ich weiss nicht genau,
wie ich damit umgehen soll.
Das Wachstum ist gehemmt, die Reben
entwickeln sich nicht wie normal.
Da fehlt einfach die Erfahrung.
In der Zwischenzeit,
etwas weiter weg,
macht sich Basiles Vater,
Pierre Monachon,
Vizepräsident der Winzerbruderschaft,
auf den Weg, um die Fete
des Vignerons anzupreisen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Meine Damen und Herren, hier blicken
wir auf etwa 400'000 Rebstöcke.
Und zu Ehren all dieser Rebstöcke
und der Winzer,
die sie bewirtschaften,
eröffnen wir in wenigen Augenblicken
den Billettverkauf
für die Fete des Vignerons 2019.
Vielen Dank.
(Alle) Cinq, quatre, trois,
deux, un, zero!
Der Verkaufsstart der Billette
ist ein bedeutender Moment
für die Organisatoren, die hoffen,
dadurch die Finanzierung
der nächsten Fete sichern zu können.
Trotz dieser Herausforderung
kommt Pierre nicht umhin,
auch an andere Probleme zu denken:
jene, die den Betrieb betreffen.
Mein Sohn möchte eher
in Richtung Bio-Anbau gehen.
Das hat dazu geführt,
dass er dieses Jahr im Frühling
zu viel Unkraut hatte,
was die Reben eingeengt hat.
Die Pflanzen,
die Blüten leiden darunter,
tragen leichte Trauben.
Die sind schon gut.
Aber dieses Jahr
ist es wirklich sehr trocken.
Na ja, er wird sich
an diesen Moment zurückerinnern.
Er musste diese Erfahrung machen,
jetzt weiss er es besser.
In einer Vater-Sohn-Beziehung kommt
immer irgendwann der Moment ...
Ich hab vermutlich mit meinem Vater
das Gleiche gemacht.
Als Sohn sagt man sich dann:
"Der alte Mann geht mir auf
die Nerven mit seinen Ratschlägen."
"Ich will es auf meine Art machen."
Also macht er es so, wie er will.
Aber da steckt viel Erfahrung drin.
- Ja, aber das muss nichts heissen.
Das ist jetzt sein Problem.
Wir hatten anfangs den Ehrgeiz,
einen möglichst biologischen Weinbau
zu betreiben,
unter geringem Einsatz
von Unkrautvernichtern.
Aber angesichts der Umstände
musste ich die Ansprüche
etwas herunterstufen.
Es kam der Punkt,
an dem wir gezwungen waren,
Herbizide einzusetzen, um den Reben
etwas Luft zu verschaffen.
Das ist verrückt,
denn anfangs sah alles gut aus.
Die Dicke der Triebe
war eigentlich gut.
Und dann verlangsamte sich
das Wachstum plötzlich.
Sich ständig anpassen,
jede Saison aufs Neue.
Immer im Wissen, dass man als Winzer
nur einen einzigen Versuch
pro Jahr hat.
Entscheidend
ist immer das Endergebnis.
D.h., dass der Wein
am Ende hervorragend sein muss.
Nicht nur gut, sondern hervorragend.
Letztlich kann Basile so viele Dinge
ausprobieren, wie er möchte.
Was zählt, ist, dass das Endprodukt
hervorragend ist.
Für mich war immer nur
das Beste gut genug,
und für ihn ist das auch so.
Aber bei manchen Versuchen
muss man dennoch sehr aufpassen.
Nun ist er es,
der den Wein dann verkaufen muss.
* Sanfte, antreibende Musik *
In Genf, nach den Frühlingsgewittern,
kümmert sich Damien
um die Gesundheit seiner Pflanzen.
Den Merlot finde ich besonders
schön, v.a. wegen seiner Blätter.
Aber er hat lange gebraucht,
um sich zu erholen.
Hier sieht man noch immer die Spuren
des Hagels vom letzten Mal.
Die Hagelkörner
haben überall Schaden angerichtet,
v.a. an den Ranken.
Es freut mich, die Pflanze
jetzt so zu sehen, so grün,
und bald kommen die Trauben.
Sie ist auch frei von Krankheiten,
daher sind wir wirklich zufrieden.
Jetzt gilt es,
die Sommerkrankheiten fernzuhalten.
Bei der Nachbarparzelle
ist es anscheinend
zu einem Befall durch Echten
und Falschen Mehltau gekommen.
Dieses Weingut
gehört dem Kanton Genf,
und dessen Önologe
ist zufällig gerade vor Ort.
Hier sieht man, dass ein Grossteil
der Weinbeeren betroffen ist.
Sie sind bereits ausgetrocknet.
Zudem ist auch das Blattwerk
befallen.
Und hier ist der Schaden an Trauben
und Blättern sehr gut zu erkennen.
Der weisse Belag hier,
das sind Mehltausporen,
die vom Wind verbreitet werden
und neue Blätter und Beeren
befallen können.
Da steckt
ein riesiges Schadenpotenzial drin.
Mehltau ist hochansteckend.
Man wird ihn kaum mehr los.
Damien kann nur hoffen,
dass sich die Pilze nicht
auf seine Parzelle ausbreiten.
Das zeigt, dass es im Laufe
der Saison gewisse Momente gibt,
in denen man wirklich
keinen Mist bauen darf.
So ist es.
In solch schwierigen Jahren
merkt man,
dass Bio-Anbau
nicht ganz so einfach ist.
Man muss viel wachsamer sein.
Manchmal ist es notwendig, in guten
Jahren das Maximum herauszuholen,
um dann die schwierigeren Jahre
zu überstehen.
Man muss mit Verlusten leben können
und lernen,
wie man mit Krankheiten umgeht.
Die Gesetze der Natur akzeptieren
oder sich vor der Natur schützen.
Auf den Anhöhen Luganos,
bei Tamborini,
setzt man nicht auf Bio-Anbau.
Die Arbeiter haben die Reben besprüht
und Netze
gegen die Unwetter gespannt.
Auf diesem 70 h grossen Weingut,
das von Valentina geführt wird,
greift man auf industrielle
Schutzmethoden zurück.
Der Betrieb ist so gross geworden,
dass es nicht mehr drin liegt,
dass ich an den Rebstöcken
oder im Weinkeller arbeite.
Auch heute steht für Valentina
wieder Öffentlichkeitsarbeit an.
* Rassige Musik *
In einem grossen Restaurant
in Lugano,
an einer sog. Ladies' Night.
Inmitten der Unternehmerinnen
berichtet Valentina
über ihre Erfahrungen
als Geschäftsführerin des Weinguts.
Guten Abend. Vorhin bin ich
gar nicht dazu gekommen,
Sie alle zu begrüssen.
Herzlich willkommen!
Ich engagiere mich
zu 200 % in unserem Familienbetrieb.
Als Vertreterin der nächsten
Generation und auch als Frau.
Es ist natürlich nicht immer einfach
mit all diesen Männern.
Mit meinem Vater, meinem Grossvater,
und auch
mit all meinen Mitarbeitern,
einschliesslich des Önologen
und der Kellermeister: alles Männer.
Ihre Ansprache kommt gut an -
zumindest bei den Frauen.
Was die Männer anbelangt,
so trifft Valentina
auf einen der wenigen Vertreter
seines Geschlechts an diesem Abend.
Hey!
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Es ist ein wirklich schöner Abend.
Ist alles gut gelaufen?
- Ja. Sehr gut.
Valentina hat gelernt,
mit Männern umzugehen.
Ich bin unter Männern aufgewachsen.
Ich komme gut damit klar,
fühle mich wohl.
Männer sind einfacher als Frauen.
Wegen morgen:
Ich musste etwas umorganisieren.
Mattia wird kommen.
Ich kann nicht überall sein.
Kein Problem.
- Morgen wird Mattia hier sein.
Wunderbar.
- Heute Abend bin ich da und ...
Kein Problem. - Ich kann
nicht alles gleichzeitig machen.
Es ist einfach schade
um deinen Anblick.
Ach, hör auf!
* Sanfte Musik *
Es brennt nicht stark genug.
Machen wir's wie die Hexen!
An diesem frühen Morgen im Juli
treffen Marion und ihre Enkelin
Gayane gerade Vorbereitungen,
um das biodynamische Weingut
zu besprühen.
Voila.
Über dem Feuer
wird ein Präparat aus Kieselerde,
also Quarzsand, hergestellt, das
die Rebstöcke kräftigt und schützt.
Gayane, holst du die Kieselerde?
* Lockruf *
Nicht fallen lassen, gell!
Es ist kostbar.
Wie viel ist das etwa?
Schon 12 g.
Für 3,5 ha.
Drei mal vier, zwölf.
Ja, 14.
Im Sommer
streuen wir Kieselerde aus.
Sie gibt dem Boden Energie,
den Mikroorganismen im Boden.
Mit der Kraft
dieser biodynamischen Präparate,
die wirklich Medizin
für den Boden sind,
erzielen wir
viel gesündere Lebensmittel.
Das Ziel ist es,
einen gesunden, fruchtbaren Boden
mit einer Krümelstruktur zu haben.
Zieh ihn ein bisschen raus!
- So?
Nimm die Hand etwas hoch, damit man
mehr sieht. Du musst gut aufpassen!
So?
- Ja. Aber du musst Stopp sagen!
Heb den Schlauch bitte etwas an!
So?
- Ja.
Wunderbar.
Voila.
Wenn wir,
die wir das Land bewirtschaften,
unseren schönen,
krümeligen Boden anschauen
und ihn mit konventionellem Boden
vergleichen,
dann müssen wir
nicht lange überlegen.
Man kann ihn anfassen, ihn riechen.
Und wenn man sieht, was da wächst -
die Pflanzen
haben eine andere Struktur,
sie wachsen in die Höhe,
stehen zwischen Himmel und Erde,
tragen glänzende Blätter.
Bei den Reben
zeigt sich das sehr deutlich.
Mal sehen,
ob du es diesmal schaffst.
Ganz leicht, oder?
- Ja.
Geht es so?
Besprüh ihn auf dieser Seite,
den armen Apfelbaum.
Super!
Hier drüben auch noch.
Schau mal, wie ruhig es ist.
Die Ruhe vor dem Sturm, sozusagen.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Rivaz bereitet sich Basile
auch gerade auf das Besprühen vor.
Ebenfalls im Morgengrauen,
um der Hitze auszuweichen.
Anderer Ort, andere Methoden,
die von Generation zu Generation
weitergegeben werden.
Nur die Art und die Geräte
sind heute anders.
Sie ziehen einen Schutzanzug an.
Da hat sich einiges getan.
Ich habe damals
mit meinem Vater angefangen.
Er tat das mit nacktem Oberkörper,
einer Mütze,
einer Zigarette im Mund.
Am Abend war er jeweils ganz blau.
Aber die Jungen heute
machen das anders.
Sie tragen einen Overall,
eine Schutzmaske, Schutzbrille.
Tja. Und das,
obwohl die Mittel heute
viel weniger aggressiv sind
als früher.
* Motorenlärm *
Heute muss Basile
die ganzen 3 ha des Guts besprühen,
an einem einzigen Tag.
Die gesamte zukünftige Ernte schützen
unter dem geringstmöglichen Einsatz
von chemischen Produkten.
Ich stehe mit einem Bein
im Bio-Anbau
und mit dem anderen
im konventionellen Anbau.
Solange Kräuter, Honig und Gross-
mutters Hausmittel funktionieren,
ist das für mich in Ordnung.
Und so jongliert man
dann mit diesen beiden Ansätzen.
Heute hat sich Basile
für ein Mittel auf Kupfer-
und Schwefelbasis entschieden.
Stoffe, die als natürlich gelten,
auch wenn es nicht so scheint.
Wir schützen uns sehr gut,
obwohl die Mittel
letztlich natürlich sind.
Wenn man einen Spritzer ins Gesicht
bekommt, dann passiert nichts.
Das sind Mittel
aus dem biologischen Weinbau.
Ich weiss noch, mein Grossvater
schützte sich natürlich nie,
und so trug er Verletzungen davon,
hatte Schorf an den Armen usw.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es anders gewesen wäre,
hätte er sich geschützt.
Aber wir achten schon
auf solche Details.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Graubünden
hat Irene den Schritt gewagt.
Diesen Sommer erwartet sie
den Besuch des Inspektors,
der ihr das Bio-Siegel
ausstellen kann.
Und heute ist es nun so weit.
Ja, hallo.
- Hoi. Salut, Irene.
Schauen wir die Formulare an.
- Genau.
Was brauchst du?
Am liebsten gleich den Parzellen...
- Den Parzellenplan.
Parzellenplan.
Zwei oder vier?
Mindestens eine Reihe, je nachdem.
- Okay.
Es liegt in deiner Verantwortung.
Du musst sagen können,
ob es einen Abdrift gibt oder nicht.
Die Herausforderung im Bio sind ...
... das Beobachten, die Erfahrungen.
Das ist das A und O.
- Nicht nur im Bio.
Das ist grundsätzlich so.
Ja, aber im Bio muss man noch mehr.
Man kann nicht korrigieren.
Genau, es gibt keine Polizisten.
Dann können wir in die Reben gehen.
- Genau.
Wie war es mit Hagel?
Dieses Jahr hatten wir nur wenig,
man sieht es kaum.
In den Blättern
sieht man teils etwas.
Aber ...
Wie hier z.B. einen Riss.
Oder hier ein kleines Loch.
Und wie sieht es mit Mehltau aus?
Solche Dinge?
- Überhaupt kein Problem.
Das war nicht
der erste Besuch des Inspektors.
Er hat sich eine Meinung gebildet.
Zusammenfassend zur Kontrolle:
Ich stelle fest,
du hast das voll im Griff.
Du bist auf gutem Weg für Bio.
Man sieht, dass du dich
schon länger damit befasst.
Und eigentlich
schon länger Bio bist,
als dass du angemeldet bist.
Nächstes Jahr wieder?
- Ja, genau.
Gut, tschau, Irene.
- Tschüss, merci.
Gute Wimmet!
- Ja, danke.
Dieses Wetter müsst ihr ausnützen.
- So heiss sollte es nicht sein.
Aber es wird wieder frischer.
Tschüss, merci.
Für Irene verlief dieser Besuch
problemlos und ohne Überraschungen.
Es ist nichts Verrücktes,
denn ich weiss, worum es geht.
Von daher ...
Es macht mich stolzer,
einen guten Wein im Keller zu haben,
denn das ist Arbeit.
Das ist viel ... komplexer.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im August in Genf.
Luc trifft sich mit Damien.
Vater und Sohn
zählen nun die Tage bis zur Ernte.
Ich denke, die Blütezeit steht fest.
Wir sind jetzt doch schon
bei 100 Tagen.
Bald werden sie reif,
und dann muss es schnell gehen.
Wir können uns schon mal
darauf einstellen,
dass die Erntezeit
etwas kürzer sein wird als sonst.
Daher werden wir wohl nicht
den Zuckergehalt haben,
den man in heissen,
sonnigen Jahren erwartet.
Ich weiss es nicht so genau,
aber es ist doch eher untypisch.
Wir werden sehen.
- Es ist nicht wie 2003 oder 2015.
Gut. Wahrscheinlich
fangen wir mit denen hier an.
Insgesamt ist es nicht schlecht,
aber wir könnten uns den Reifegrad
ja mal kurz anschauen.
Die brauchen noch gut zwei Wochen,
denke ich. - Ja.
Witzig, die Kerne
sind ja noch ziemlich grün,
aber sie sind schon knackig
beim Draufbeissen, nicht?
Ja. Also einige
sind schon ganz hübsch.
Die Entwicklung ist auf gutem Weg.
Dann müssen wir schauen,
wie die werden.
Diese Beeren sind noch etwas ...
Ein paar sind schon welk -
die, die abgestossen wurden.
Die werden verdorren, denke ich.
Und die hier sind etwas verdeckt.
Das ist wirklich schön. Es bereitet
Freude, die Reben so zu sehen.
Um die Erntezeit
abschätzen zu können,
vertraut Damien auf die Erfahrung,
die ihm sein Vater vermittelt hat.
Und doch ist er es, der entscheidet,
an welchem Tag und zu welcher Uhrzeit
es so weit ist.
Dazu beobachtet
und probiert er die Trauben,
nutzt die Erkenntnisse aus der langen
Weinbautradition auf seinem Gut.
Nun beginnt für alle Schweizer Winzer
die lange Zeit des Wartens.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gegen Ende des Sommers
sind die Trauben
zwar noch nicht ganz bereit
für die Ernte,
aber für manche
doch schon sehr schmackhaft.
Da wurde alles abgefressen,
das waren die Vögel.
Aber wir hatten auch schon
Dachse und Rehe.
Und das ist erst der Anfang.
Danach kommen die Ameisen.
Hier sind sicher schon
zwei, drei Ameisen am Werk.
Die Reben
müssen mit Netzen geschützt werden.
Ihr Landarbeiter, Christian,
ist gegangen.
Nun sucht Marion nach einem Ersatz.
Eigentlich sollte ich arbeiten,
nicht rumspazieren.
Jetzt haben wir einiges zu tun:
Netze spannen, die Birnen pflücken,
und viele andere Dinge.
Es ist zwar nicht die Ernte,
aber dennoch Arbeit.
Die Angestellten ihrer Kollegin
Marie-Therese Chappaz
sind zur Verstärkung gekommen.
Setzt ihr bei Marie-Therese
auch die blauen Netze ein?
Ja, die gleichen.
Auf der anderen Seite fressen
schon die Rehe die Trauben ab.
Letztes Jahr
hattet ihr auch schon Probleme.
Ja, da waren es die Vögel.
Und dann die Rehe.
Es gab Frost.
- Wenig.
An den Pflanzen kaum.
Ja, im Flachland gab es Frost.
Der Gamay ist ganz eingefroren,
unten bei der Seilbahn.
Aber dieses Jahr ist es schön.
Es ist trotzdem eine schöne Arbeit.
Wir haben
noch viele Netze zu spannen,
falls ihr noch mal
wiederkommen wollt.
Kurz vor der Ernte müssen die Trauben
besonders geschützt werden:
Nach Unwettern und Krankheiten
müssen die Winzer jetzt auch noch
Massnahmen gegen den Andrang
der Tiere ergreifen.
Nach diesem trockenen Sommer sind
die Wildtiere hungrig und durstig,
von den Insekten ganz zu schweigen.
Die sind schon reif,
da haben sich schon die Wespen,
Bienen und Vögel
zu schaffen gemacht.
Ja, davon hast du mir erzählt.
Wenn das Wetter
warm und windig bleibt,
sollte das aber kein Problem sein.
Aber wenn Sonntag oder Montag
Regen angesagt ist ...
Das scheint ja leider
der Fall zu sein.
Willst du die Lese vorziehen?
- Um zwei Tage vielleicht.
Okay, wir richten uns danach.
Perfetto.
Neben den Wespen bedroht
auch eine kleine Fliege die Reben.
Sie hat die Arbeiter dazu gezwungen,
die Trauben mit einem eigenartigen
Gemisch zu besprühen.
Federico, ist das alles Merlot?
Ja, das ist der Merlot
für euren Ludiano.
Ja, der ist super.
Aber ihr musstet die Reben
doch noch mit diesem weissen Pulver
schützen, Kaolin, oder?
Genau. Pierre,
du kennst dich da besser aus.
Kaolin, das ist weisse Tonerde,
die Federico als Vorsichtsmassnahme
eingesetzt hat,
vorbeugend
gegen die Kirschessigfliege.
Wann war das, vor einer Woche?
Dieser neue Eindringling
bereitet Valentina Sorgen.
Eine kleine asiatische Fliege,
die die Ernte ruinieren kann.
Die Fliege
legt ihre Eier im Innern der Traube.
Dadurch
entsteht eine Essigsäuregärung,
die die Weinherstellung
sehr schwierig macht.
Die betroffenen Trauben
müssen zwingend entfernt werden,
denn mit ihnen kann
kein Wein mehr hergestellt werden.
Der Essiggeruch
ist wirklich sehr stark.
Die hier riechen auf jeden Fall
nicht nach Essig.
Nur ein paar wenige kleine Trauben
sind beschädigt.
Im Moment haben wir hier
also noch keinen Befall.
Aber sie müssen
noch zwei Wochen durchhalten.
* Sanfte Rockmusik *
Zwei Wochen vor der Ernte kann man
die Daumen drücken oder feiern.
An diesem letzten Augustwochenende
öffnet Irene
die Tore ihres Weinguts
für die breite Öffentlichkeit.
Anlass ist eine kleine Feier,
die sie gemeinsam mit Tochter Europa
und Sohn Johannes
auf die Beine gestellt hat.
Es ist die letzte Ruhe,
bevor die Ernte beginnt.
Es ist die Zeit des Wartens,
was passiert.
Wir selber
können nicht mehr viel machen.
Vielleicht
beschäftigen wir uns auch,
um unsere Nervosität zu überspielen.
Wir treffen Johannes an der Bar an,
wo er gerade zwei Stars des
deutschen Fernsehens vor sich hat.
Die Fernsehköche
scheinen Schweizer Weine zu schätzen.
Das ist 100 % Pinot Noir.
Ein Teil mit Kaltmazeration gemacht,
damit er Farbe kriegt.
Ein Teil ist ganz abgepresst,
damit er die Frische bekommt.
Ein sehr gefälliger Wein,
ist gut zum Essen kombinierbar.
Zur Wurst und Fettigem ...
Der macht die Zunge gleich sauber.
Sehr schön.
- Ja, finde ich auch.
Hat sich gelohnt.
Danke.
- Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Wiederschauen.
Kommen Sie gut nach Hause.
- Alles Gute!
Der heute internationale Ruf
der Bündner Weine
schafft eine grosse Nachfrage
für dieses kleine Gebiet.
So kurz vor der Ernte
erhöht sich dadurch
der Druck auf die Qualität der Lese.
In trockenen und heissen Jahren geht
der Zuckerhalt sehr schnell hoch.
Und die Säure schnell runter.
Darum sind wir froh
um die kalten Nächte,
damit die Säure konstanter bleibt.
Wir können nicht ernten,
wenn sie nicht reif sind.
Mit einem hohen Zuckergehalt
haben wir viel Alkohol.
Aber die Traube muss reif sein.
Ja.
Speziell ist auch
die frühe Herbstverfärbung.
Sieht aus wie im Oktober.
- Ja, logisch.
Ohne Wasser
konnten sie nichts aufnehmen.
Und es ist erst August.
- Genau.
Jetzt ist es ein Nervenspiel.
- Ja, wie jeden Herbst.
Hier Vogelfrass.
Rehe hatte ich auch.
- Ein Reh könnte es auch sein.
Eher Rehe.
- Zum Glück beginnt bald die Jagd.
Ja, es gibt viele Ränder.
Das sehe ich dieses Jahr
aber zum ersten Mal.
Aber das ist teils vermutlich auch
durch Trockenstress bedingt.
Für die nächste Woche
wünsche ich mir kühle Nächte.
Und warme Tage mit ca. 20-25 °C.
Lieber weniger.
Und nicht mehr zu viel Regen.
Das ist mein Wunsch.
Und v.a. keinen Hagel.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Willst du eine kleine Traube essen?
Na, Traubenmädchen? Willst du eine?
Ja? Aber nur eine.
Hier. Ganz vorsichtig.
Mmh.
Und Linette? Hier, vorsichtig.
Jawohl.
Und dann kommt noch
eine Traube in Papas Tasse,
damit er schauen kann,
wie es um den Zuckergehalt steht.
Hier nehmen wir auch noch eine.
Das sind Stichproben.
Wir zerdrücken die Trauben,
damit der Saft rausfliesst.
Damien hat Verstärkung dabei für die
letzte Amtshandlung vor der Ernte:
den Zuckergrad der Trauben ermitteln.
Schau, wir machen Saft.
Er ist leicht rosa, siehst du?
Maya, rühr das ein bisschen!
Das kommt dann hier drauf.
Machst du das?
Ach, so machst du das.
Hier drauf, auf das Glas. Wunderbar.
So, jetzt machen wir das
noch mal richtig,
weil es ist doch relativ wichtig.
So.
Dann machen wir das zu,
und schauen durch dieses
kleine Guckrohr in Richtung Sonne.
Dieses Gerät misst die Grad Oechsle.
Je höher der Zuckergehalt, desto mehr
Alkohol produziert der Wein.
Basiswissen
in der Chemie des Weinbaus.
Die beiden Zwillinge
haben das schon ganz gut drauf.
Maya,
willst du auch mal durchschauen?
Gar nicht so leicht! Du musst durch
das kleine Loch schauen.
Trotz Wärme und Zuckergrad
der Trauben entscheidet Damien,
sich noch etwas zu gedulden.
In Rivaz hingegen zeigt sich
ein aussergewöhnliches Schauspiel,
aussergewöhnlich
für den Monat August.
Ich habe noch nie
im August geerntet.
Das ist das erste Mal,
dass es dazu kommt.
Das ist wohl aussergewöhnlich,
vielleicht auch nicht,
aber es könnte in Zukunft
immer wieder mal vorkommen.
Grüne Ernte nennt sich das.
Vielleicht die früheste überhaupt
in der Geschichte dieses Weinguts.
Wann war's letztes Jahr, Pierre?
Ich weiss es nicht mehr genau,
aber so um den 20. September.
Eine Ausnahmeentscheidung für
eine Rebsorte, die nicht warten kann.
Der Pinot Noir ist vermutlich
die empfindlichste rote Rebsorte.
Daher muss man sie wohl oder übel
am Tag X ernten.
Wenn man zulässt,
dass der Zucker sich anreichert,
und das dann schlecht
mit der Anreicherung
und Entwicklung der Aromen
korreliert,
hat man einen
im Alkohol unausgewogenen Wein.
Das wollen verhindern.
Daher nimmt man sie etwas früher,
damit der Alkoholgehalt stimmt.
Der Wein schmeckt trotzdem gut,
die Trauben sind ja nicht mehr grün.
Nach der Lese kommt alles
für eine Woche in eine Kühlkammer,
damit sich die Weintrauben
etwas setzen können.
Die Ernte muss doch gefeiert werden.
Es ist das erste Mal, dass wir
die Lese im August durchführen.
Aber nur ganz knapp,
heute ist der 31.
Na dann, zum Wohl!
- (Alle) Zum Wohl.
Danke, dass ihr gekommen seid.
An diesem ersten Tag
durften Pierre und Basile
auf die Unterstützung
von Familie und Freunden zählen.
Die Erntehelfer werden
in ein paar Tagen eintreffen.
Hast du die Leute
für die Ernte zusammen?
Noch nicht ganz.
- Soll ich mich darum kümmern?
Nein, das mach ich schon.
Guten Tag. Damien, freut mich.
Wir haben vor, in der Woche
vom 10. September anzufangen.
Aber das genaue Datum
müssen wir noch bestätigen.
Aber so ist es geplant.
Wir werden in der Woche
wohl drei bis vier Tage arbeiten
und dann in der Woche darauf
weitermachen.
Würde das für Sie passen?
Super, da freue ich mich.
Vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Ja, gern geschehen.
Schönen Tag noch, auf Wiederhören.
Wir haben schöne Trauben
an den Reben, sieht alles gut aus.
Das wird eine schöne Ernte, denke
ich. Wenn denn das Wetter hält.
In Beudon
bereitet sich Marion allein vor.
Es ist das zweite Jahr,
in dem sie sich ohne Jacky
um die Lese kümmern muss.
Oje,
ich hab noch nicht alles erledigt.
Ich habe den Kontrolleur angerufen,
um ihm zu sagen,
dass wir mit der Ernte
begonnen haben,
aber er hat sich
nicht mehr gemeldet. Sonst noch was?
(Am Telefon) Die Litermenge
oder die Anzahl Kilogramm
müssen berechnet werden.
- Wie immer.
Aber das muss nicht heute sein.
Nein, wir haben dafür
fast einen Monat Zeit.
Erster obligatorischer Schritt
für Marion:
den kantonalen Beauftragten
informieren.
Guten Tag. Ich beginne jetzt
mit der Ernte in Beudon.
Falls es da noch etwas Besonderes
zu beachten gäbe,
könnten Sie mich bitte
zurückrufen?
Danke. Schönen Tag noch
und auf Wiederhören.
Wir sind gelernte Landwirte,
wir wollen keine Zeit mit dem
Ausfüllen von Formularen verlieren,
mit der Bürokratie,
die immer mehr wird.
So fehlt uns dann die Zeit,
um unseren eigentlichen Beruf
auszuüben.
Aber so ist es nun mal.
Dem muss man sich halt fügen.
* Leichtfüssige, antreibende Musik *
In Beudon sind gerade die Erntehelfer
angekommen - aus aller Welt.
Und in allen Rebbergen ist der
Startschuss für die Ernte gefallen.
Wunderschön!
Farbige Kisten
zieren die Schweizer Hänge,
bereit für die Früchte
eines ganzen Jahres.
* Leichtfüssige, antreibende Musik *
Wenige Wochen für die Ernte
der Arbeit eines ganzen Jahres
und letztlich: das Urteil.
Er hat sich
gegen Herbizide entschieden
und bezahlt den Preis dafür.
Das Gleichgewicht zwischen
Quantität und Qualität finden.
Das ist eine schöne Lese.
Die Ernte - hier
werden die Spannungen sichtbar.
Ich habe möglicherweise etwas
gesagt, das ihm nicht gepasst hat,
und nun ist er weg.
Wenige Tage,
an denen alles kippen kann.
Ich wollte nur was holen,
dann fiel ich von der Leiter.
Von Schmerz bis Leidenschaft -
überall in der Schweiz
erleben die Winzer den Höhepunkt
eines ganzen Jahres.